the diamondbacks and the national play
league player of the week cole calhoun
come home to chase field one week left
in the regular season the diamondbacks
look to finish strong win some games and
of course help plot the course for the
future but tonight it's all about the
rangers and the diamondbacks it's your
d-back starter the lefty caleb smith his
third start with the diamondbacks since
his acquisition from miami
and still trying to build up that arm
strength in innings after he missed all
of august with kovid and they're loaded
for joey gallow
popped it up this might stay playable
foul ground for escobar
and they call infield fly affair now the
dangerous rook that odor
swing and a miss he got strikeout number
two
one more to go for caleb smith right now
the only pitch that caleb smith is
consistently commanding is that slider
anderson taheda
the shortstop
swang and of this caleb smith
the magic man he walked the first three
and leaves him loaded
jordan lyle's on the mound tonight for
the rangers coming off his best start as
a ranger and seven starts this year he's
got it era a little over seven uh his
whip is close to one and a half and 29
to 21 strikeout to walk ratio and cool
calhoun is next
swinging to miss
calhoun strikes out and the inning is
done so neither team able to score in
the first inning
go to the second
the runners move up to second and third
and it will be up to the catcher carson
kelly
this one in the air to center field and
a routine fly ball ends the threat for
the diamondbacks two innings
in the book joey gallo popped up his
first time oh two to gallow
high in the air to deep left peralta's
on the warning track
sat down by caleb smith who settled down
nicely
even when you're behind in the count
throw some strikes don't put these guys
on base
here's a ball that's hit hard to short
but backhanded by tajeda and his strong
throw will take care of walker
diamondbacks go one two three for the
first time tonight against jordan lyles
and we head to the fourth rangers
nothing diamondbacks nothing arcadia
high school product sam huff
it to deep center var shows out there
still backing up but he's got it
and caleb smith has set down seven
straight and 12 of the last 13.
here's escobar now escobar is singled in
the second somewhere to call time nobody
does escobar has got a base hit
eduardo waited it out
he wanted no outs to start the fourth
escovar two for two here is david who
singled in the second
1-1 is bounced to second under the glove
of odor
here comes cole calhoun escobar hustling
into third and it's one nothing
diamondbacks our big guy for the freight
train is two for two
o'dore got to the spot just didn't get
his glove down quickly enough it snuck
underneath into right field no chance
for paving smith now
haven sends one to right center gallow
is there here comes escobar
they don't cut it off that time and rbi
for pavon smith make it two nothing
zolac has walked in flight out
old calhoun backing up and right
riley smith strands that one out single
d-backs lead the ranges to nothing
cole calhoun first and third one out
slicing out to left center field eli
white is there var shows at third here
he comes
marshall beats the throw at his
three-nothing diamondback o'doro for two
rings up odor works a one two three six
finding he set down five in a row
three outs on eight pitches for riley
smith it's three-nothing diamondbacks
there's nick ahmed over two
base hit down the line this is gonna get
peralta home to make it four nothing
it's in the corner ahmed is rounding
second and headed for third nick
comments got an rbi triple first triple
this year for nick four nothing
diamondback carson kelly they're on the
corners now still nobody out there
carson hits a fly ball deep to left
field eli white at the wall that's gone
carson kelly
diamondbacks open up a big lead here in
the sixth inning that's the fifth of the
year for the diamondbacks catcher
bounced up the middle by smith
backhanded by van meter what a play josh
van mater and he got connor philipe
that's a nice play coming in on that
slow chopper up the middle of the field
second and third two outs
right there there's your shutout and the
diamondbacks take game one against texas
seven nothing
behind the two smiths caleb and riley
nine scoreless